hi as hosts on screen we get tons of
comments on our videos here are our
favourites of 2014 hmm I love this ho me
too that's horrible on what video is
that that I believe was the video about
FBI facial recognition but this
commenter saw any comments on almost
every single one of the videos that I
present I don't know a stalker yet but
one can dream but my favorite comment by
a troll is in response to a rape culture
video that we did this person says rape
is illegal therefore there is no rape
culture it's just a feminist myth to
promote more man heat mmm you must not
have scroll down and seen an even worse
or a comment on that very same video
from Orthodox legacy who says this tune
is great I think I might just go rape
someone now seriously I have never seen
anything on TV internet or magazines
that has made me want to rape someone if
it is anyone's fault I would say it's
the women they dress in these skin tight
clothes booty shorts short skirts high
heels etc is it the woman's fault in
room one is it when installed Yammer
it's the internet open it is the
Internet's at home i usually get these
weird interesting exchanges on twitter
and to be fair i tend to bait them a
little bit i mean i called up one
slightly funny one there was news that
egypt had arrested a whole lot of people
who were celebrating a gay wedding so I
said Egypt tries to fix the country's
deep political economic and social
divisions by arresting happy people
celebrating a gay wedding and then there
was this guy he sort of decided to chime
in oh wait let me play them will let me
play the guy are you one of them am I
one of what are you a GE asterisk why
what's wrong with typing the word gay
why the asterisk in the middle I just
don't like writing it are you a GE
asterisk why I'm sorry Eunice I'm
already taken but I'm sure you're very
damn I am NOT one of them I hate G
asterix why yes hate them fuck g Asterix
wise one of my favorite trolls on our
app actually is about all of our
Ferguson coverage and it was in a
response to some questionnaire that we
put out there because it was you know
sparking lot of debates about the civil
rights movement this person very
astutely noted that it wasn't blacks
that fought to be free it was white that
fought for blacks to be free you know
cuz those guys in white sheets they were
just you know they were trying to help
so those were our top troll comments of
2014 sorry if you didn't make the list
this year but there's always next year
and sure they'll be plenty more vitamin
surprise us what do you get when you
take a community of gamers a conspiracy
theory about the media and a bunch of
misogynistic attention-seeking trolls
the hashtag gamergate